JAMES WARD: Hi.
I'm James Ward, a developer
advocate at Google Cloud,
and this session is on
comparing Docker methods.
So we're going to go
over Docker files,
build packs, and some great
things with GraalVM and jib.
So we're actually going to
do this all as live demos.
So here we go.
Let's start out exploring
containers by just using them,
and then we'll
take a look inside.
Let's just run a
container locally.
So I'm going to say
Docker run, and then I'm
going to tell it to map a port.
So I'm going to use
port 8080 and tell
it to map the port
in the container 8080
to my local host
8080, and then we'll
give it the container to run.
And this is going to be
either a Docker Hub container
or a URL to a container I'm
going to give it the URL to gcr
dot io cloud run slash hello.
So that is a URL that will
pull the container down from.
So let's run this
and see what happens.
Now I already had the
container on my local machine,
so it didn't have to
download anything.
But you can see it's actually
started up the container.
So it uses virtualization
on my machine
to take the contents of
the container and run them,
and that's how we get containers
to have a consistent running
across different platforms
and operating systems and all
that Let's go take a quick
look at this application
in my browser.
So I could just go to local
host 8080, and there we go.
We've got now our
application up and running.
OK.
So we're able to run
that container locally,
and that's great, but one of the
great things about containers
is that they're easily portable
so that we can run them
other places, too.
We can run them in
Kubernetes, we can run them
on a service called Cloud
Run, or anywhere else
they can run containers.
So I'm going to go into
Cloud Run on Google Cloud,
and we're going to go
create a new service,
and we'll say we want to
run it in the Iowa region.
We need to give it a
name, so we'll just
call us one hello
containers, and I'm
going to allow
unauthenticated invocations,
and then I need to give
it a container image URL.
So I'm going to,
again, give it that gcr
dot io cloud run slash
hello, and then I
can just take create.
So that will now pull that
container down and start it up
on underlying infrastructure
for my service on Cloud Run.
Looks like that's all
done and ready to Go,
so now I can just
open up this URL.
And there we go, now we see
that container running there
in the browser.
Cloud Run is serverless
for containers,
so it takes containers
as the deployment unit
and then it will start
up as many instances
as demand dictates to
run that application.
And of course, we can see
logs, and details, and metrics,
and all the other great stuff
here for this service running
on Cloud Run.
And we could do the same
thing on Kubernetes.
We can run this
the same container
on Kubernetes or anywhere
that Docker will run.
OK.
Now we've seen that container
running both locally
and on Cloud Run, but let's
actually go look and see
what that container is.
To do this, I'm going to
use a tool called dive.
And so I'm going to say let's
do you dive on that container.
So now we're getting
a bunch of information
about this container
and what's in it.
There are layers in a
container, and these layers
have different files
on a file system.
So you can think of a container
as kind of like a zip file
with some metadata about what
other layers it depends on.
And so we can build
up a stack of layers
to have everything that
we need in our container
so that it can run.
So we can see
different layers here.
You can see those
up in the top left,
and we can see the first layer
was only 5.6 megabytes, so
nice and small for
that one, and then
we can go and browse the
files that are in there.
So you can see, this looks like
a basic operating system here,
maybe Ubuntu or Debian
based operating system,
or BusyBox it looks like.
So that was the first
layer, and pretty small.
Then we can see
some other layers
that are added on top of that.
We add some CA
certificates, then
there's another
layer which looks
like it's adding some
server pieces to it,
and then there's an
index dot html that
gets added in a layer, and
then some SVGs, some assets.
So the whole image size, the
whole container image size
is only 17 megabytes
for this particular one.
So that's nice and
small, everything
that's needed to have a portable
container that can run anywhere
that runs containers.
OK.
So that's our basic
intro to containers,
but now let's talk about
how we create containers.
To explore creating containers,
let's go look at an application
that we want to take from
source code to a container.
So what we're going to
do is go over to GitHub.
I have a repo under my
GitHub, James Warden,
comparing Docker methods, and
there's some different branches
that we're going to
be walking through.
The first branch we're
going to walk through
is the Docker file method, and
we'll open this up in IntelliJ
so that we can explore
it a little better.
I'm going to be using
a Java Maven project
for our explorations here.
But of course, really anything
can be turned into a container
these days.
So all of this stuff
should apply no matter
what technical
technology you're using.
If you're using Node, or
Go, or Python, whatever.
It should be able to be easily
turned into a container,
and we'll have a lot of
similar methods for doing so.
OK.
So for a first method of turning
something into a container,
we're going to
use a Docker file,
and this is kind of the
traditional standard
for how you take something
and turn it into a container.
Let me first walk you
through this project
so you can get an
idea for the layout.
So this is a Maven project.
So we have our pom
file which defines
how our project is
going to be built,
and then we have our source
code which, in this case,
I'm just using a plain Java
class that's starting up
a server, and when
there's a request,
it's going to respond
with hello world, so
super simple application.
So let's take a look at how
this works for the Docker file
method.
I have a Docker file, and the
first part of the Docker file
is talking about
how this thing is
going to be built
from source code
into something that can run.
So what I do is I start
from another container,
and I give it a
indicator as builder
which is going to
say this is just
the builder part of
the package and won't
go into my final container.
I set the work
directory to slash app.
I copy the contents of my
source into the container,
then I run Maven compile,
and then jar clone and jar,
and that will create the
jar file so that I can run
my application in this case.
So I've got that now
in the as builder part,
but I need to now take that and
put it into my final container.
So I do another from, and this
time I give it the base image
that I'm going to use for this,
for my production container
image.
And so I'm using
the open JDK jre,
and then I'm copying
from the builder
that jar file that was created
from Maven compile and jar jar,
and then putting that
on slash server dot jar,
and then I tell it
a command to use
to when the container starts.
So I say Java minus
jar, that's server jar.
OK.
So that's a pretty
straightforward way
to go from source
code to the container,
and we can go try this out.
So to try it, I'm going
to say docker build,
and then I'm going
to give it a tag.
The tag is either the URL
or the local coordinates
to this thing.
And in this case, I'm not going
to use a remote registry, which
we'll talk about later.
So I'm just going to say that
my tag is going to be-- whoops.
Let's copy this and
paste it, and then I'm
going to say colon where
I get a chance to specify
like a version or
something like that.
And in my case, I'm going
to say this is docker file,
and then I need to tell
Docker what to actually build.
And so I'm going to say
dot, and so it's going
to find the Docker file there.
And now what Docker will
do is it'll go download
if it needs to the different
layers, the Docker container
layers, so that
it can build this.
You'll see it's downloading
those from, in this case,
Docker Hub is where it's
getting that, adopt open
JDK open JDK 11
from, and now it's
walking through all the
steps in the Docker file,
running the Maven build.
So now because this is running
outside of my local file
system, it doesn't have access
to the Maven local cache.
So it's downloading
all the Maven stuff
that it needs, and it
has the JDK already,
and it needed to download Maven
and then Maven's dependencies.
So it's downloading all
that from Maven central,
and then it's going
to do the compile,
should be able to start
that up in a second.
And then once it gets compiled,
it'll create the jar file,
and then from that
jar file, it'll
create that final
container image.
OK.
So it's created the
jar file, and you'll
see it says it's removing
those intermediate containers
because it didn't need those
any longer for the final image,
and then it's assembling
the final image starting
with the open JDK 11
JRE as the base image,
and then copying that
server jar file in,
and then setting
up that command.
OK.
So now we can actually
run this thing.
So what I can do is
say, let's docker run.
I do need to map the
port like I did before.
Let's map it to
8080, and then I'm
going to tell it that
container image to run.
So let's run that thing
and see how it works look.
Let's go to our local
host 8080, and great.
Our hello world works.
OK.
So we've got this
working locally
and we've got the
container image,
but now let's go
use that dive tool
and take a look at what's
actually in this container
and how it's structured.
So diving in, we'll see
that dive opens it up.
We can see the layers.
We see a base image that
is our operating system,
and then it's got a
few other pieces here
that are tweaking some things
in the operating system.
It looks like it's installing
some CA certificates and font
config into the container,
and then this 129 meg layer
is probably our
JRE, and then we've
got the final layer which is
copying in our server jar file
and adding that
into the container.
And that one, in our
case, is pretty small.
So total here of 229
megs for all the layers
of our application.
Now it's nice that we have this
layering of Docker containers
because that makes the cache
validation really great
because if I create a new
version of this container that
only changes that final
layer with a new jar file,
then it doesn't
have to recreate,
and in a lot of cases, doesn't
have to pull down those layers
that it already has.
So there's these
sha digests that
make it so that caching works
really well for each layer
that our container
is assembled from.
OK, so really great
caching support
with the layers in Docker.
OK.
So that was the first method
for creating a Docker container
with a Docker file.
All right.
Now for the second method
of building containers,
we're going to use
something called jib.
So I'm going to go and
switch my branch in this repo
over to the jib branch,
and we'll check that out.
And now let's go
pull up the pom file,
and we'll learn a
little bit about jib.
So jib is a JVM
based library that
can plug into Maven and Gradle,
and creates container images.
So all we have to do in the case
of Maven is add that plug-in,
and now we can use jib
to build our container.
So the source code
didn't change.
Nothing else changed.
You'll see that I don't
have a Docker file anymore
because we don't need one
because we're going to use jib,
and we could do this
for Maven or Gradle,
and I think there's other JVM
based build plugins as well.
OK.
So to do this,
we're going to call
Maven with a target
of jib docker build.
So let's go do that here.
Run that.
So we're going to first run the
compile then jib docker build,
and we're going to tell
it the image name that we
want to store which is comparing
docking methods colon and jib.
OK.
Now jib assembled
in our container,
and it did that super
fast because jib
doesn't actually use the
typical docker method
to create these containers.
It has its own implementation,
and it's super fast
and has great caching
support as well.
So let's go do our
dive on this container
now and take a look at what's
in inside of this container.
So dive in, and we'll see
that our total container
size is a little bit
less this time, 197 megs.
I think because we're probably
using a different base image.
So we've got our base image
with our operating system,
different pieces the
operating system, and then
the JVM that we're using is
probably that layer there.
And then the jib plugin kicks
in and adds some pieces in,
and it looks like
there's a layer here
that's used for our
dependencies, which we'll
get into in a minute, and
then the final layer which
is our class file for
our code of this project.
So jib did a great job creating
this nice little container
for us.
Now let's run this
thing and make sure
that everything works.
I can just say let's run
the jib, one of those,
and let's go refresh to make
sure that our container works.
Yay.
It does.
OK.
So that's our container
created with jib.
One of the nice things
that jib does, though, is--
you may have seen it
there-- it adds a layer four
our dependencies
in our application.
So in this case, my application
doesn't have any dependencies.
It's just a basic
Java application,
but let's switch over to
the jib Spring Boot branch,
and then we'll have
some dependencies.
So in the case of Spring Boot,
I have some dependencies,
in this case, just the
Spring Boot starter WebFlux.
So that is my dependency
with whole bunch
of other dependencies
underneath it
that I'm going to use in here.
And so if we go back and run
that Maven Docker build again,
and we'll give this
a different name.
We'll call it spring
jib dash Spring Boot,
then it's going to
take the dependencies
and copy those dependencies
into a layer as well.
And you'll remember that
the caching in Docker
makes it so that the cache
and validation is really nice.
So let's use dive and
go check this thing out.
OK.
So looking at this,
we'll see that now there
is this layer added by
jib which is 18 megs,
and you'll see over
on the right that this
is all the dependencies
that come in
from my dependency
on Spring Boot,
so 18 megs of
dependency that got
pulled in for that Spring
Boot WebFlux dependency,
and then all the way down
to my particular code that
was added on another layer.
So if we don't change
our dependencies,
then that layer doesn't
change, which is super nice.
Only when we change the
dependencies with that layer
change and only when we change
our application code would
this top layer change.
So total now, 216
megs with those
dependencies with most
of that being the JVM.
OK.
So that's the jib
method, and that
works on any JVM based
build, but let's take
a look at yet another method.
So I'm going to go switch over
to the build packs branch.
Let's check out this one.
So build packs are in
incubating CNCF standard,
and it's a way to be able to
really throw almost any source
code at a tool, the build packs
tool, and have the build packs
know how to turn that source
code into a container image.
So there's no plug-in
in my pom for doing
this, nothing special in there.
There's nothing in my
project, no Docker file,
and what we're
going to do is run
a tool called pack that will
turn my code into a container
image.
I'm going to be using the
Google Cloud build packs.
So there's different build
packs that you can use,
and if we go to GitHub and go to
the build packs repo on Google
Cloud platform, what we'll
see is information about
the Google Cloud build packs,
the ones that we'll be using,
and the different languages
that are supported.
Go, Node, Python,
Java, and .NET.
OK.
So that means that we can
give it any application built
with those technologies,
and it should
be able to turn that
into a container image
without our code or our
build plug-in having
to have any knowledge of how to
go be turned into a container
image.
So let's give this a try.
I've already installed
this tool called pack.
You can just download it
from the build pack website,
then you give it
the builder image
to use, which is also
a Docker container,
and so this is the build pack.
So the Java build
pack, the Go build pack
from Google Cloud
Build packs, and then
we give it the tag that
we're going to use.
So let's run pack
build on this thing
and turn that source code
into a container image,
and then we'll take a look
at the container and dive.
There's also a nice
caching in build packs.
They do a good job of
preserving stuff across builds,
and you'll see that it
did this restoring phase.
So first, it actually
did a detecting phase,
and it detected that, hey,
this is a Java application,
and it knows how to
build applications,
so then it restored
from cache our M2 cache,
so it didn't have to
re-download stuff.
It did the maven clean
package, and then it
exported the layers.
OK.
So now we've got our--
let's see.
That was build back.
Let's go now dive into that one.
So let's run this on
the build pack one,
and let's try build packs.
I think that's what
it was, plural.
OK.
So now this is pulling
that into dive,
and now we can see
the layers that
were created from build
packs for this application.
We can see a base image,
which looks like the operating
system, and then some other
things on top of that,
and then we get down into this
large layer which is probably
the JVM layer,
and then we have I
think a layer for
dependencies and a layer
for our application,
something along those lines.
So similar layering to
what we saw with the JVM,
but you'll see
that, in this case,
the base image is that
it chose were larger
than the ones that
were chosen by jib.
You can customize
that if you want,
but the total image
size for this one
is 436 megabytes, but
really nice that we didn't
have to have anything
in our project
that told it how to create a
container image from our source
code.
OK.
And just for the
sake of validation,
let's go run our docker run,
give it the port 8080 to 8080,
and run this thing, and make
sure that our application built
with build packs works.
Hello world.
Great.
It still works.
OK.
So that was the
method of using build
packs to go from our source code
to our Docker container image.
Now let's check
out. another option
which is going to use the Docker
file option we saw before,
but in the case of JVM
projects, can result
in really small binaries.
So for this one, I'm
going to switch over
to a branch called GraalVM, and
for the GraalVM one, what we're
doing is we're using the
Docker file because we're
doing some stuff that
we can't do with jib
or with build packs.
What we're going to
do is we're going
to use this thing called
GraalVM to ahead of time
compile our JVM
based application
into a native executable.
So I'm giving it the
GraalVM base image there
for our builder, and
then I'm installing
into here native image, which
is a tool for GraalVM to create
those native images,
and then I'm also
downloading a library, a
native binding library, that we
can use so that our
application doesn't have
any runtime dependencies
on anything,
not even an operating system.
And then I'm going to do my
Maven compile, create my jar,
and now I'm going to run
the native image tool,
and I'm going to tell
it some parameters
here for when it creates
the native image.
I'm telling it to use that
MuslC bundle that I downloaded
earlier and a few other things.
Static is what does
the static binding
to the native libraries.
OK.
Now here's the cool part
is that for final image
I'm saying from scratch, which
gives me a plain nothing in it
Docker image, and
now I'm copying
the output of
native image, which
is this binary
executable called webapp,
copying that into the
container, and then
telling it to run that webapp.
OK.
So this is a JVM
based application
that we're turning into
a native application
with no built in bindings to
the native code that's needed.
So let's go run this one
which I'm going to just copy
this Docker command here.
Because we're using
a Docker file,
we're going to do the Docker
build and give it that tag
there.
OK.
So now it's doing the builder
stage of the Docker build.
It has downloaded those
native image components
and the MuslC components, and
now it's doing the Maven build.
So again, it's going to
have to download the Maven
stuff for Maven central
so that Maven can run,
and so that'll take a minute
to download everything
that it needs, and then
it'll create our jar file--
or compile the code,
create the jar file,
and then it will run native
image on that jar file
to be able to turn it into
that native executable.
So all this takes a
little bit of time.
And just a
recommendation, no matter
what method you're using, I
only create my container images,
usually, as part of
my CI/CD process.
When I'm developing locally
for JVM applications,
I'm just using the
standard Java run tooling
with a JVM installed locally so
I get a really quick feedback
cycle, and I'm not creating
container images as part
of my local development.
I just have my CI/CD
server create those images
because those are
the artifacts that
are needed to run in
Kubernetes or Cloud Run
or wherever you want to
run your container images.
OK.
So native image is now
running on our jar files
and has ahead of time
compiled that JVM application
into a native binary, and
then it has stored that
into the Docker container, and
now we can run this container,
and let's make sure it works.
So let's say run, and
then let's map our port.
OK.
Run that thing.
So one of the things that's
really nice about GraalVM
native images is that they start
up really fast and usually use
a lot less memory.
So they work great in
serverless environments
that benefit from that.
OK.
Looks like everything's working.
That's awesome.
Now let's use our dive
tool, and let's go
explore our native image
that was created here.
So now you'll see, because I
did that from scratch, I only
have one layer in
my Docker container,
and that one layer only
contains that one file webapp,
and it's 11 megs.
So I was able to
have no operating
system in this container because
all the native bindings are
built into the executable
that it needs, so super small,
but this is still
a JVM application,
just through GraalVM native
image was able to ahead of time
compile the whole thing down
into a native executable.
So super cool, and
one thing that you
can do with containers and
with JVM based applications.
OK.
So that was exploring
different ways
of creating Docker containers
and some of the impacts
that you have with doing so.
Now let's learn a little
bit about Docker registries.
Docker registries
are places that we
can store these
containers so that they
can be easily accessed
from different machines.
So there's a number of
Docker registries out there.
One of them, the most
typical one that people use
is just Docker Hub.
So Docker Hub is
hub.docker.com, and you
can sign up for an account
and store your containers up
on Docker Hub, and a
lot of the containers
that we're using as base images,
that's where they come from.
Now, for your projects
on Google Cloud,
there's two other places where
you can store your Docker
containers.
So let's go over into the Cloud
console and check those out.
So there's the
container registry
is the traditional place
to store containers.
So you can see I've got a
bunch of containers stored up
on the Google
container registry,
and you'll remember from
when we did the build pack
sample that the build
packs are stored up there
as well, the Cloud Run
hello world is stored
up there on the Google
container registry.
There is another place on
Google Cloud which is newer,
and this is called
the artifact registry.
The artifact registry is cool
because it supports not just
Docker containers,
but you can also
store maven artifacts, NPM
artifacts, that kind of stuff
up there as well, so not
just Docker containers.
So you can check that
out, currently in beta.
OK.
So let's go back to
the container registry,
and let's go create
a container that
will store up on the
Google container registry.
So I'm going to switch over
to the-- let's go to the jib
branch here and use that one.
OK.
Let's go now back
to our command where
we're going to create
our container image.
All right.
So let's copy that command
that we used before
and paste it in here.
And then instead of
saying jib docker
build, I'm going
to say jib build,
and then I'm going to give it
the coordinates to the Google
container registry.
So I'm going to say gcr
dot io slash and then
my project ID on Google Cloud,
so that's jw demo, and then
my artifact name.
OK.
Let's try to run this.
And what it should do is
create that container image
and store it up on the
Google container registry.
So it looks like it's pushing
those layers up to the Google
container registry.
And in this case, it didn't
need the local Docker daemon
because it didn't actually
store that on the local Docker
daemon.
OK.
Now if we refresh the
Google container registry
and we come down, we should
see a new Docker container
image here comparing
Docker methods,
and then we see that one
that I just pushed there,
and then I can come and
click on this and say, let's
deploy it on Cloud Run,
GKE, GCE, or whatever.
So that's how easy it is to
be able to take source code
and get that container image
up on the Google container
registry
Let's go and walk through
one other quick step
for this which is deploying
this on Cloud Run, which you've
seen already, but
I want to show you
what it looks like if we
were to do it from that menu.
So just like we saw before,
we can create a service.
We can give it the service name.
We can tell it, yes,
unauthenticated request,
the container image URL,
and then let's hit create.
OK.
So now it's creating that
service from that source code
and deploying the new
revision, and that will be up
and running in just a second.
OK.
Great.
So it's up and running,
and there it is.
Hello world running
up on the cloud.
So if you do want to play
around with this stuff,
there is a really
easy way to do that
which is, if you go to my
comparing Docker methods repo,
and then you can pick any
of these different methods
via different branches.
Let's go back to
the jib one, then
there is a button that
you can click on here.
So let's click this run
on Google Cloud button.
And when we do, it's
going to take us
into something called
Cloud Shell, which
will automate those steps
that I've walked through
on the command line.
And so this just provides
a nice, easy way for you
to learn about using these
different methods for building
Docker containers and
deploying them up on Cloud Run.
So it's clone dot git repo
and checked out the branch
that we were on,
and then it's asking
me which project I want to use.
I'm saying jw demo.
Where do I want to deploy?
US central one is the region,
and now what it will do
is run that Maven jib
task on this repo.
So that's now running and
creating our container image
using jib, storing
that container image up
on the Google
container registry.
So there you go.
You see that it's doing that
Maven package jib build,
giving it the image parameter.
So just like we did
from the command line,
but this is doing
it all for you.
So you don't have to
remember all the steps.
Just click that button,
and you can do it
on any of those branches
within that repo,
and that'll help
you get started.
So now it's doing the
G Cloud Run deploy,
deploying that container
image up on the cloud,
and then we should see
this thing deployed and up
and running here
in just a second.
So that's a super easy
way to get started,
and that is on my GitHub.
So GitHub James
Ward, and then that's
under the comparing
Docker methods repo there,
and then you can select the
branch that you want to go see.
OK.
So our app was deployed
up on Cloud Run.
We can open it up and see once
again our lovely hello world.
OK.
So that is the comparing Docker
methods with Docker files, jib,
and build packs, and then also
some GraalVM thrown in there
for native images with the JVM.
All right.
That was comparing
Docker methods,
and I hope that
was useful for you.
I really appreciate
you watching.
Hope you got a lot of it.
Thanks.